time and space are on the same footing  in special relativity einstein's key  insight a somewhat unfamiliar conception  with today's technology it's actually  extremely easy to measure distances in  time it's actually much easier for us to  do that than to measure distance in  space thanks to the atomic clock  you see for distances in space  you need to set extremely precise  starting and ending points for every  point you measure in order for us to get  any insight on a small enough scale  experiment  before we unpack the most precise clock  ever made and the consequences of this  new experiment we need to understand the  concept of curved space time so how do i  know the curvature of space time between  us how do i measure